le directeur du Théâtre de 50 an yelin
ne manque pas d'idée et il nous le
prouve avec cette sélection de spectacle
à la fiche la saison prochaine voici
Jacques Pornon dans le
[Musique]
kiosque on a parlé village de de Peter
Hanke donc c'est une mise en scène de
salisas Nordet ça va faire l'ouverture
du du Festival d'Avignon dans dans la
cour d'honneur donc on a vraiment une
grande fierté de d'accueillir ce
spectacle chez nous dans la distribution
c'est une
distribution très très prestigieuse on
retrouve Emmanuel Béard qu'on a déjà pu
découvrir dans se trouver et puis Jeanne
Balibar le Misanthrope par exemple de
mis en scène par Jean-François civadier
c'est la première fois Jean-François
civadier vient à 5eline c'est la
première fois qu'il monte à Molière et
puis il a une particularité jean-fançois
Siad dans ses mises en scène c'est qu'il
met dans le coup le public il va le
chercher et les les acteurs vont même à
un moment donné dans la salle et du coup
on est embarqué complètement le
remplacement d'une orthodoxi par une
autre n'est pas nécessairement un
progrès le véritable ennemi c'est
l'esprit réduit à l'état de grammophone
et cela reste vrai que l'on soit
d'accord ou non avec le disque qui passe
à un certain moment le projet Luciol
voilà de Nicolas Truong qui est un
projet à deux acteurs qui est un projet
autour de texte philosophique donc ça a
l'air un petit peu abstrait comme ça et
en
réalité c'est c'est une manière de de
rendre vivante on va dire la pensée la
pensée d'aujourd'hui incarné par deux
formidables acteurs qui sont Nicolas
bouchot et Judi Henry on a aussi cheeda
qui est une pièce de Dieu deéanguna donc
auteur congolais qui va être créé à
Avignon dans la
dans la carrière boulebon qui un autre
lieu prestigieux de d'Avignon on a sans
doute qui est une création de Jean-Paul
de
[Musique]
l'or
le bal des gintouchables donc c'est
l'école porteur c'est la grande création
d'écolepteur et l'agglomération de 50 an
divine est coproducteur aussi du
spectacle donc ça c'est très important
de de souligner et donc on va retrouver
l'école porteur dans une un spectacle
qui est très très beau qui qui mélange
les âges qui mélange les styles qui
mélange aussi les agrais les les les les
performances artistique qui mélange la
musique et ça va être un très très beau
moment donc ça va se passer à la base de
loisir de Trapp c'est en coproduction
avec d'autres lieux de
[Musique]
l'agglomération il une thématique
chanson avec B on the c'est le titre
d'une chanson de Léonard Cohen donc
c'est c'est un parcours musical qui est
proposé par
Rose-Marie Stanley qui est la chanteuse
de du groupe moriarti
[Musique]
ن
والدودم
d sa femme d' qui est une chanteuse
tunisienne qui rend hommage aux grandes
cantatrices du de la chanson arabe
notamment humkalsum asmaan et
ferou
on a solot de couflet où il voilà ça
c'est une chance formidable parce que
c'est c'est très rare il le fait très
rarement et donc il va ouvrir la saison
on aura la chance d'avoir de couflet en
personne qui va nous montrer toutes les
facettes on va dire de sa personnalité
de son parcours artistique toute son
histoire personnelle et ça va être
quelque chose de très mouvant de très
émouvant de de très
[Musique]
touchant moural merzuki c'est c'est un
vrai bonheur de l'accueillir à nouveau
c'est un il a une écriture
chorégraphique qui est à la fois du Hip
Hop et de la danse contemporaine il a un
univers poétique vraiment remarquable et
le spectacle qu'on va présenter à une
vous allez le voir une CO une une
lumière et des danseurs vraiment
magnifiques quoi il est all là et Taiwan
et il a fait un travail avec des des
artistes
taiwanais
[Musique]
tu vois Julien l'eau là elle coule le
sujet de la rédaction lui il est cool tu
dis vraiment mais n'importe quoi
toi pour la première fois depuis
1686 versaill recrée un carousel
royal hérité du tournoi médiéval entre
paradquestre et jeux guerrier italien
prisé à l'époque du roi soleil et cette
semaine c'est répétition sans artifice à
pied et à
chevaler le
[Musique]
cercle regardezvous pour avoir des écs
bien
é depuis les gradins les metteurs en
scène donnent la cadence au cavaliers de
l'Académie belge d'équitation et de la
haute école d'équitation portugaise Luis
Valena ce carousel version 2013 raconte
l'histoire de qu princes étrangers venu
conquérir le majestueux soleil é
voocation allégorique du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
roi chacun des prétendants représente
une vanité humaine richesse orgueil
luxure et
force
[Musique]
à l'opposé il y a aussi le poète rôle
incarné par un amoureux des chevaux en
liberté qu'il dresse dans la confiance
mutuelle j'essaie d'avoir une relation
assez fusionnelle avec mes chevaux c'est
un gros travail de préparation avec le
cheval une fois qu'on est ami en fait il
nous donne tout voilà en gros c'est
c'est un peu ma
[Musique]
devise fron d'émotion
garanti répétition les costumières
travaillent sous une tente aménager
qu'on a commouche à
faire ah si ça
les claire passe en revue la centaine de
costumes et d'accessoires prévus pour
les soirs de
représentation ça ça s'appelle un rein
grave c'était une tenue qui est typique
du début du règne de Louis XIV qui est
une espèce de culotte avec une jupe
dessus l 14 aimait beaucoup cette tenue
là et qui une tenue contrairement à ce
qu'on peut croire extrêmement virile qui
permettait de monter à cheval des
costumes aux matières nobles reproduit à
partir des gravures des carrouselles du
Roi Soleil il y a énormément de de satin
de brocard il y a eu beaucoup de tissus
d'ameublement qui ont été utilisés parce
que c'est souvent dans ces tissu là
qu'on trouve les les motifs qui sont
recherchés dans ce genre de costume et
puis énormément bien sûr de gallons et
de passementerie puisque ça ajoute
facilement le côté baroque pour les
coiffes on retrouve des plumes
d'autruche comme sur le casque de ce
prétendant et aussi des plumes noires de
queue de coque sur cette autre ou encore
des plumes de faisant pour les turbans
des
Voltigeurs voilà un avant-goût de ce
spectacle é castre costumé inédit depuis
250 ans au finale pyrotechnique digne de
la ville
royale
[Applaudissements]
pour le metteur en scène et son équipe
de perfectionnistes c'est avant tout un
rêve d'enfant qui se
réalise on est tous conscient de créer
quelque chose qui n'a jamais été vu et
qui est en parfaite harmonie avec les
lieux dans lesquels on est c'est une
parfaite évidence mais personne ne l'a
jamais
fait
[Musique]
des dates que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet ainsi que l'ensemble de la
programmation culturelle des salles
saquantinoises aux adresses qui
s'affichent alors bon spectacle à tous
et à bientôt à bientôt
arrête 1
Go
ceż C